well we're almost out of time but I have
to ask did you ever get distracted by
bent hair in the movie because I feel
like it should have gone it's I did but
it helped me it helped me and see where
we were in I was like man this is
something right here I was like if I
look crazy like everyone else would know
they're gonna look better about
comparison I mean the windsuit with the
glasses that was the perfectly document
that I did not put on one piece of
clothing that I did not see was warm
don't tell me you weren't excited I
still wear this everybody could hear you
coming
she's so good in this movie and a big
shout out to Charlize our costume
designer who crush it like yeah like
this is all stuff when Sunny the real
Sunny came to the Set uh with his wife
and and they looked at me and and
Charlize was standing there and they
turned her and they said and his wife
said did you raid his closet like I was
wearing all stuff and she had just kind
of intuited exactly what he would wear
in fact I think we we have a gift for
you you know
somebody's going to materialize
oh look at this I thought that this is
the only thing is you have to wear them
I wish I was like skiing right now this
is incredible
[Applause]
they're super cool I'm gonna actually go
out with it fine uh one more time forbid
on Black Mountain
dinner is everywhere starting Friday and
look for it coming soon on Prime video
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody